y ahora tenemos esta extraña expresión
que depende tanto de x como de james y
que si nosotros quisiéramos graficar nos
saldría este trébol de cuatro hojas un
trébol de cuatro hojas de la buena
suerte y esto lo grafica del programa
wolfram alpha y bueno como ustedes ven
en el título del vídeo lo que quiero es
encontrar cómo cambia con respecto a x o
la pendiente de la recta tangente en
cualquiera de los puntos de esta bonita
gráfica sin embargo para esto lo que voy
a hacer lo que voy a usar es la derivada
implícita por lo tanto voy a aplicar el
operador derivada tanto de un lado como
de otro lado de la ecuación para hacerlo
de manera implícita y bueno lo primero
que tengo es esta función elevada al
cubo por lo tanto usaré la regla de la
cadena que me dice bajemos el 3 dejemos
todo lo que está dentro del paréntesis
igual le bajamos 1 al exponente y lo
multiplicamos por la derivada de lo que
está dentro y queda es la derivada de lo
que está dentro aposté es la derivada de
x cuadrada con respecto a x
que es 2x + la derivada de cuadrada con
respecto a x y otra vez utilizamos la
regla de la cadena es 2 y las derivadas
de ye con respecto a x recuerden que
siempre derivamos esta expresión con
respecto a james y lo multiplicamos por
la derivada de ye con respecto a x eso
cuando queremos hacer una derivada
implícita y bueno entonces cierro este
paréntesis y del otro lado que me va a
quedar utilizaré otro color va a ser
igual y tengo la derivada con respecto a
x de 5x cuadrada y cuadrada y para
derivar esto lo primero que voy a hacer
es sacar este 5 que no me va a servir de
mucho entonces voy a sacar el 5 lo voy a
poner afuera del operador derivada
porque es una constante y después tengo
la derivada de x cuadrada y cuadrada que
es una multiplicación de funciones por
lo tanto primero tengo que derivar una
función y multiplicarlo por la segunda
función y después derivar la segunda
función y multiplicarlo por la primera
entonces la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x
que multiplica al cuadrado
esto tengo que sumarle x cuadrado x
cuadrada no le hago nada esta vez y la
tengo que multiplicar por la derivada de
cuadrada con respecto a x usando la
regla de la cadena me va a quedar 2
veces y por la derivada de ella con
respecto a x ojo como estoy derivando
algo que tiene que ver con ye con
respecto a x al final le pongo la
derivada de ye con respecto a x y bueno
aquí tengo el ye cuadrada y el cuadrada
su derivada y por otra parte este es la
derivada de éste la derivada con
respecto a x de ye cuadrada y bueno aquí
tengo de x cuadrada aquí tengo en la x
cuadrada normal y por otra parte tengo
aquí su derivada la derivada con
respecto a x también recuerden que es
una multiplicación de funciones y por lo
tanto la derivada es esta suma que tengo
a la derecha y bueno a partir de ahora
todo lo que no tenga que ver con de jane
de x lo voy a poner de color morado esa
base es la convención
entonces voy a multiplicar esta
expresión es que está demorado por todo
lo que está de verde y me queda 3
por 2 x 6 x que multiplica a x cuadrada
más cuadrada elevado al cuadrado y
después 3 x 2 james edad 6 yen que
multiplica a x cuadrada malla cuadrada
elevada al cuadrado x cuadrada malla
cuadrada elevada al cuadrado que no se
me olvide y a esto hay que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de ella con respecto a x
que lo voy a poner de color verde y
bueno del otro lado que tengo del otro
lado tengo un 5 que multiplica a 2 x de
cuadrada y un 5 que multiplica a x
cuadrada por 2 por la derivada de ye con
respecto a x entonces 5 por 2 es 10 10 x
cuadrada si 5 x 2 es 10 si 10 x cuadrada
y bueno después que hay que hacer 5 por
2 también es 10
entonces me va a quedar más 10 veces x
cuadrada bien y esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de ye con
respecto a
y bueno ahora si lo que voy a hacer es
juntar términos semejantes por lo tanto
voy a hacer operaciones aquí abajo del
lado derecho tengo algo que tienen que
ver con de jane de x que es 10 x
cuadrada y por lo tanto lo voy a pasar
restando del otro lado me va a quedar
menos 10 x cuadrada james y aquí también
menos 10 x cuadrada james y este nos
verde diferencial de jane diferencial en
x y aquí derivada de hoy derivada de de
con respecto a x y bueno ahora si nos
fijamos del lado izquierdo tenemos este
6x que multiplica a x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada elevado al cuadrado que no
tiene que ver con dejen de x por lo
tanto lo vamos a restar de ambos lados
de la ecuación menos 6 veces x x x
cuadrada malla cuadrada elevada al
cuadrado y ahora sí voy a hacer las
operaciones correspondientes de este
lado esto se cancela a 1 que suma y lo
otro que resta se cancelan y aquí que me
quedan me queda 6 que multiplica a x
cuadrada más y cuadrada elevado al
cuadrado
10 x cuadrada james todo esto todo esto
depende x de james de x es igual y del
otro lado que tengo tengo que estos dos
se van a cancelar se hacen cero porque
uno suma y el otro resta y por otra
parte tengo 10 x de cuadrada menos 6x
que multiplica a x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada elevado al cuadrado y ahora sí
si lo que quiero es la derivada de ella
con respecto a x voy a hacer desaparecer
este factor que tengo aquí y lo voy a
pasar dividiendo entonces voy a tratar
todo esto y me queda que la derivada de
ye con respecto a x es igual a 10 x
cuadrada a todo esto que está aquí
entonces copiar y pegar a todo esto que
está aquí ajaja estoy haciendo trampa y
después lo tenemos que dividir entre
todo esto que está acá entonces copiar
pegar y lo pongo aquí esto está genial y
lo único que me hace falta es la raya de
división entonces la voy a poner aquí
y ya con esto tengo la pendiente de la
recta tangente o el cambio de ye con
respecto a x o la derivada de ye con
respecto a x de cualquier punto de este
trébol que yo tengo aquí y por ejemplo
si quisiéramos saber cuál es la
pendiente de la recta tangente en este
punto que tengo aquí bueno pues lo
primero que me tengo que fijar es cuánto
vale en x que supongamos que toma un
valor como por aquí tenemos un valor en
x también nos fijamos en un valor en 10
y estos dos los sustituimos en esta
extravagante ecuación que tenemos aquí y
después de realizar todas estas
operaciones podemos ya saber la
pendiente de la recta tangente justo en
ese punto del trébol